oh Jesus
what is that
so good to see you you look stunning
congratulations on the film my favorite
part of the movie was like how gory it
is it's it is so gory that I wanted to
first ask you what was like the wildest
scene you shot when it came to guts and
limbs
um I think the visitor center sequence
um you know the bear takes out a few
people in that sequence when the closet
opens we haven't shown anyone what's in
that closet you've seen it so I think
the the stuff in the closet was the most
intense and we actually ended up cutting
back on some of it because I think
people were too like I didn't want
people to literally want to vomit
I want them to get close but not
actually go there can you tell me a
little bit about what you cut out
because I'm so curious now you know it's
just a more lingering shots more on
things things sort of like moving a
little bit like you know not quite dead
things even though they're about to be
things like that okay I loved the gore
was there anything that you wanted to do
that you couldn't when it came to the
gore like was there no everybody was I I
presented the idea for how gory I
thought the film would be right at the
very beginning everybody bought into it
Lord Miller Universal we were all on
board we all kind of held hands and went
forward with it we had incredible
Prosthetics work you know people making
Limbs and heads and you know anything
that we needed all of the blood that was
you know used Sunset Buckets of Blood
you know if you're gonna have a bear
who's high on cocaine going on a bender
and you know ripping into people there
had to be some sort sort of like
heightened sense of what that is and I
very unfortunately went down the rabbit
hole at the beginning of looking at what
real animal attack victims look like and
I do not recommend that but if you were
to do that you would see that we did a
very good job of representing how gnarly
that can be no you did incredible I was
reading that you actually did that I
mean that this stuff must have come up
in your dreams at some point when you're
like so engrossed in in a in a project
that happens for me at least so thank
you for going through that for us I
think it paid off what was one of uh the
most wildest moments on set like if you
close your eyes and think back like what
was the moment Elizabeth where you were
like I can't believe I'm I am directing
a movie about America
um gosh what was the last one was that I
mean probably with with the hikers the
very beginning Hana Hoekstra was uh she
played a small role in Charlie's Angels
We really loved her
um she came in for this so willingly and
it's in the trailers too like her being
dragged back she did that like herself
her own stunt multiple times ripped up
her entire stomach I mean she was so
committed to it that I was kind of
horrified and and I I really didn't want
to keep going and she was like no I want
to get it right you know she was just so
into it and I think that for me the
commitment of the people around me is
what really got me through the whole
process I was just stunned by everyone's
you know total commitment to like
getting this thing right across the
board can I just tell you that that
opening scene was my favorite well
because I am in nature a lot I have an
alter ego nature Naz and the line
Elizabeth said I lost it no one else was
laughing in the theater but when they're
like we get so lucky in nature I'm like
I've said that so many times when I've
been gone for a while it was so
realistic I wanted to ask you what tips
would you have
um for people who love nature who maybe
would encounter a bear on cocaine well I
I'll tell everybody no matter what top
survival tips well
um we we tell you in the movie if it's
if it's brown lay down and if it's black
fight back like that is the truth you're
very unlikely to come across a grizzly
bear in the lower contiguous 48 states
um they're really only in the very
northern states but black black bears
are pretty predominant all throughout
the US they're also very friendly I
don't want this movie to like be like
Jaws where it causes people to really
fear you know bears in the woods just
stay away from them you should not be
going up to wild animals period full
stop doesn't matter what they are like
leave the animals Alone look don't touch
that's my main advice
I love that I love that you brought it
back to that because I'm very conscious
and I love Wildlife a lot but I also own
bear spray so there's there you go you
just have to be safe
um do you was there ever any point a
real bear on set no but I'm so happy to
hear you ask that question because it
means we did a really good job creating
a bear out of CGI
no we never had a real no real bears no
real animals on set no animals were
harmed in the making of the movie or
used or ever contemplated
um maybe some bees that we had to catch
but that was about it nice I I was
reading and keep hearing about Cokey the
bear which what can you explain what
that is it was a face
we did create a just ahead of the bear
um with like it's full full fur and her
markings she's uh Cokey as we call the
bear has particular markings so you know
that it's our bear and that Bear Went
came to set every every day as sort of a
reference for lighting for framing you
know if we put the bear at for angles
for the camera
um and so that the crew and cast knew
what the bear was going to look like
because of course they're acting with a
guy in a in a black suit and
um green balls you know and and marks on
the ground so this was a way for
everybody to go oh okay that's how big
its head is That's How big its nose is
That's How big its eyes are going to be
yeah do you have Cokey the bear at home
I cookie now lives at my house yes
Cookie's in my office and terrifies all
who enter that don't know that they're
gonna see him it's so cool I want to see
a photo of it I also love that you guys
called it Cokey um another thing I loved
about the film obviously was getting to
see Ray Liotta the iconic Ray I would
love to ask you what was it like working
with him and what you think fans can
expect from his last performance
I loved working with him he was
fantastic he came so joyfully and to set
every day he was so game
um for this project I I really felt like
um he's somebody with he's so charming
and he has a real mischievousness about
him and I felt like that little twinkle
that's what this character needed and he
brought that in Spades
um he really loved working in Ireland
he'd not uh you know lived in this
beautiful little town and my favorite
memory of him is actually of him uh
walking arm in arm with his fiancee JC
down the street after dinner laughing I
I saw them through a window and in my
mind's eye when I think of Rey that's
what I picture I love that I love when
you have like a beautiful uh sort of
image that pops yeah that was beautiful
thank you for sharing that
um before I go I you know first of all
again such a joy to meet you and get to
talk to you about this I really loved it
there's a lot of talk about this movie
I've heard you I've read interviews
where you've talked about the risk of
this film for you personally and I feel
like we're in this kind of special
moment where it's yours and the world
hasn't seen it yet
and so I kind of just want to know how
you're feeling right now I'm I'm
cautiously optimistic you know I I know
that the movie is really thrilling to
audiences I've seen it with audiences so
I know that the ride is real and that
the laughs are real that the scares are
real I just want people to be
entertained you know this this was not
meant to be uh anything more than that
like I I made this movie in a pandemic
chaos was all around us I just wanted to
bring people together for a communal
experience I wanted to sort of Honor
some of my favorite filmmakers and films
from the past I really felt like all the
references came together for this movie
in a great way and I have an incredible
cast and I cannot wait for people to see
this cast me too and I'm so proud of you
thank you for making it connect but just
because you said that I have to ask you
one more thing I wish I had like a
million minutes with you is there a
specific reference that you would love
for people to pick up on because I I
love film references there's a little
bit of Stand By Me and a little bit of
um Jurassic Park in the movie we we are
a literal exact shots from Jurassic Park
in this movie in the tree sequence you
want to expand this world at all would
you do cocaine shark at all everyone
everyone's asking it's got to be a great
script you know that's the main thing I
gotta know like what's the shark's
motivation
the bear it did cocaine
[Music]
so obviously you know you guys were
guys from an actor Alan Henry I think
that's his name who was nice there and I
was wondering if there were any
memorable interactions with him that you
guys had on set I mean will you see
you see Alan's
giant self walking around you know just
on stilt yeah on all fours at the end of
the day it's a grown man and a black man
at the end of the day
on yeah like you out here
foreign
kicking rocks it's just like weird to
look at there's no way around it we're
all professional we're all actors but
it's just like ours
get out of here bro
you Giant
were there any was there any specific
moment that you guys had with him that
you're just like you just couldn't my
first day I like you know you show up to
the first day of a movie it's like first
day of school and I got in my trailer
and I was like have my stuff and I was
putting away whatever and then I opened
the door and they were doing the
practice of the running and he had all
his stuff on and was running in the
parking lot and doing the bear run it
was wild it took a little video yeah it
was great
O'Shea do you have one that like sticks
out to you like that I mean him and
Alden were pretty close in a certain
scene and that's just not cool to look
at all the time uh you know it's funny
the first few minutes but then it's like
we ain't get this shot yet I'm
uncomfortable
[Laughter]
he's such a dope guy
um he's from New Zealand if I'm not
mistaken I I think I'm right on that I
think you're right but yeah he's a dope
dude yeah hearing stories about all his
creature work on yeah he's like Lord of
the Rings yeah um you know him and I got
ice cream together
I bet after that
we had some post-coil ice cream yeah
I'm a professional
I'm actually crying
he said I bet after that
at least you could do okay what was that
what as much as you can tell me and us
I'm sure people are gonna you know be
watching this before and after the film
what that scene was like for you it was
fun you're you know you're doing it and
I mean you just try I watched a lot of
videos of real bear attacks and stuff so
that's what kind of keeps you in the
thing of what it would really be like
because it's not funny when it really
happens yeah
yeah you stop laughing real quick
um oh Shay I was I I've heard you talk
about
Alden having this sort of wind-up
process before getting into it that was
one thing that you could Regale us with
what that is
all right so all that is the first is
the first person I've ever worked with
that really do like he got this thing
where
he winds up into whatever the first line
of the scene is and like you'll see him
start pacing and he'll start like they
start visiting their shoulders start
going and then when action happens he
rolls into the scene like we were just
talking about it and it's impressive but
yeah it's the wind up it's just like you
know he's getting that engine going and
once it's going the lawnmower is on baby
and uh yeah it's definitely something
that I think I'm gonna steal from you
you're pretty good lawnmower the
lawnmower man lawnmower man over here
but yes the windup you got a pace yeah
goes back and forth don't talk to him
he's in the zone you might get killed
that's just how he is
I just want to watch movies from now on
with you both co-starring
this interview
this is it right here Alden does O'Shea
have a wind-up sort of process or
something that you can speak to
different uh
no she's so fun you know Shea is so fun
he's making the whole cast laugh he's
yelling out stuff and all the Irish
people are cracking up and uh oh damn
and uh you know it's really fun what's
the damn just it's just it's just a lot
that's not really an inside joke yeah
Duffy says yeah I just you know I'm real
good Ireland I'm real good at cursing I
come from a long line of cursors and uh
yeah you know it's just adjectives
sometimes to get myself in the zone
right and uh yeah I'm glad you enjoyed
it we played some game about naming the
movies or something oh yeah I throw
random random trivia right questions
like you know give me 20 Jim Carrey
movies and Everyone is always like all
right yeah I got that easy until you get
to about 16 yeah and it's like that's
right so yes man yeah I I love yeah yes
man oh that's always a good one Mr
Popper's Penguins but anyway
it's a funny game keep us keep us busy
on set yeah
that's amazing you guys are both so
hilarious I have to ask you then what um
because this energy is so good what
would your top survival tips be for
people who would encounter a bear on
cocaine number one don't go that's for
sure any survival thing to go
don't run yeah I think I learned more
about how to deal with bear attacks
during the movie I've kind of I need to
remember though what I learned I don't
really remember but don't run is a big
one yeah huge one and if you're lost and
you need water you suck up on a button
you take a button off your shirt and you
suck on it it stimulates saliva and that
keeps you uh hydrated that's not so bear
related but it's still important yeah
for anyone who's watching this that is
also uh stuck in the woods right anyone
watching this stuck in the woods they
just have reception they can watch so
black black bears you can like scare off
grizzly bears you just dubbed down we
gotta be right about that and cocaine
Bears you're done for right yeah it's
over we gotta be right about that I'm
I'm on planes all the time and I'm like
oh I know it I know what I'll what I'll
do because I've seen the video so many
times that I'm like what if I forget in
the moment yeah exactly exactly we're
all like that yeah exactly I sit and
watch Naked and Afraid and I just think
to myself there's no situation where I'm
gonna be naked you know it's not really
a good show to really judge myself
I'm just afraid clothed and scared
clothed and scared I would watch that
um before I let you guys go you had just
the incredible experience living
experience of being able to work with
the iconic Ray Liotta wanted to know
um what that was like you know what was
it like playing off him and and what can
fans expect from his last performance
yeah I mean he's such a phenomenal actor
it was so thrilled I remember doing some
of the scenes with him and just like
being in the scene and and it's one of
those experiences where you know when he
really brought it and we're really
connected that way it was just thrilling
because he was so
and just a really sweet man had a lot of
fun with the movie
um and uh yeah I'm really grateful I got
to work with him yeah I'm a man grateful
is you know that's the perfect word um
in my career I've been able to work with
a lot of cool people and then like you
know Ray Liotta is Iconic and you know
just making him laugh cracking jokes on
on set
uh it was the news was just so shocking
the first person I called was Elizabeth
like there's no way and she goes yeah I
know and US filming I had to go do ADR
and just seeing him while you're doing
ADR it just gives me chills but you know
we loved having Rey
um I think he would have loved the film
and I expect everyone else to love it as
well you're safe Bears can't climb trees
of course I can
laughs
this film really stands up like pretty
far apart from the other work that
you've done so I was curious
when you read the script you know like
what was your first reaction Liz and I
uh were talking about a different
project together
um a completely different
tonally different project and
um she called me the next day and said
hey do you want to read this thing that
I'm directing this wacky movie
and it was just at the height of covid
and everything that was going on and how
intense that was and
it was just crazy enough that I was like
that's exactly what I should go do
you know it was like such an escape from
just like how
intense everything was for everybody and
um and then Margot Martindale who I
worked with on the Americans text me and
said are you doing this movie and I was
like are you doing this movie
and then I was like now I'm definitely
doing this movie and so it was just
Margot and Jesse Tyler Ferguson and I in
the woods laughing our darn heads off
like with Liz on a microphone going
okay now the Bear's eating his face off
now his legs squirting blood and it's
it's flying off now now he's eating his
stomach but I mean it was just so gross
and so wacky and
um in fact
they had a screening so Margo and Jesse
and I could all watch it together here
in New York yeah and we were just
screaming crying laughing at each other
all being
you know devoured by this bear in really
gross ways it's so funny is there like I
I now I wish there was a cut of
Elizabeth like screaming at you got like
a behind the scenes oh it's out there
somewhere yeah it's out there somewhere
so amazing and it's always so fun I
don't want to call this out of character
for you and project on you but I always
like doing things that are out of
character for myself and um I don't know
so it feels cathartic in a way it feels
like you know yeah I think you know
since covid I I don't think I've done
something that feels like depressing or
I just I think we have enough of that
right now it just feels you know like
the lighter stuff
it feels uh easier right good it feels
feels good if I close my eyes and I and
someone asked me to picture one image of
this film it I love fashion and it would
no doubt be the incredible pink Ensemble
that you were wearing
the costume designer will love that love
it yeah shout out to the costume
designers of every film but also I was
like I need this outfit if I asked you
to close your eyes and just picture one
image whether it was behind the scenes
or on set Like Cocaine bear what comes
to mind Margo Martindale
um when she first holds the gun on the
bear and she was doing she was on this
crazy
um machine that the stunt set up where
she was holding the gun on the bed and
Jesse and I are just in the background
watching her laughing like tears
streaming down I was for sure gonna pee
in my pink jumpsuit and the this machine
like she's holding the gun and then this
machine like Yanks her out of frame
where the bear is like ripping her and
we and her hat falls off and Jesse and I
people were actually filming us because
we were laughing so hard rolling on the
ground laughing that's amazing that's an
incredible image another one I had is
just obviously of all the cocaine and of
course there was a bunch of fake cocaine
on set I was wondering if you knew what
they used in you know for that white
powder I don't know what they used we
just always used real cocaine but I
don't know what the kids I don't know
what they did in their scenes but oh so
you guys have real cocaine on set
Terry we're just meeting today you can't
do that the producers just went what the
is she saying I'm like guys I'm
just trying to be honest
um uh yeah I'm from Miami so that's
pretty believable exactly yeah you can
roll with this right
um no it was like sugary something I
didn't actually do any scenes with that
um the kids did and like Jesse did
because he falls in it but so I should
ask him I think it was like sugar some
kind of sugary something okay that's
interesting that's cool to know I was
also that's so funny I was also
wondering
um you know Alan Henry is the person who
was the bear on set yeah what was it
like interacting with Alan playing the
bear and do you think that he had the
hardest job on that
I think um
grown men having to wear unitards is
hard uh in front of you know at work I
think that's a tough job
um but no they're amazing the WETA guys
you know I've worked with those guys
before they are incredible and it does
help enormously to be not just imagining
but to have someone who has the movement
and then
you know even having someone who's
supposed to be like kind of sneaking up
behind you you feel that so it only
helps but I do have to say hearing
Elizabeth screen you know what's
actually happening Blow by blow is also
really fun yeah that sounds like a
play-by-play I need to like listen I
think that's the one I'd pick totally
because that also it's more imaginary
you know like there's no constriction in
the imagination yeah it's hard to think
you know Silly yeah right right so fun
oh my goodness do you have uh survival
tips for people if they were to
encounter a bear on cocaine in the wild
oh uh I sure don't I I mean at that
point do some with the bear and hope for
the best because it's not going to end
well it's really not gonna end well for
you if our film is any indication
not many make it out alive in our film
yeah that's that's a great tip I mean
that's a great tip it would probably
hurt less too I think so if you got
attacked yeah you're gonna go out go out
big you know yeah 100 percent
um what was it like working with
Elizabeth or Liz as you call her she's
so
um she has like a real easy confidence
to her and
um she's just a pro she's been doing
this forever I mean I feel like some of
my one of my favorite things I remember
seeing her in was wet Hot American
Summer and she plays out like trashy
girl like really sloppy French kissing
Paul Rudd she's so funny she's so smart
she's totally capable and the thing um
about her as a director she's really
unflappable like she's so you know like
it would start pouring rain and she
wouldn't freak out and like lose her and
like yell at people she's like okay this
is what we're doing now like she's just
she's a very capable
uh confident person and that lends
itself very well to directing
she can run a huge crowd it was at the
height of covid there were so many rules
there were so many like you know things
holding us back and she just you know
did it all with ease she had a complete
vision of how gory and how wacky she
wanted this to be and she really fought
for it and um I think she did a great
job and I hope this does really well for
her me too I I loved the gore I actually
got to talk to her about it because I
didn't wasn't even expecting it to be
that gory nor was I that's amazing and
it went for it so good uh Carrie you are
so hilarious yourself I was curious did
you have any scenes with Ray Liotta the
late iconic I did no I didn't have a ton
with Ray
um but yeah I mean crazy uh and yeah he
was awesome he was just easy and awesome
and kind and sensitive and and there and
a good sport you know what I mean
because we were all doing such crazy
stuff
um
but yeah yeah crazy Liz saw him a little
bit more than I did